also im Juli wurde ja folgendes
beschlossen dass Alb VVG wofür stehen
diese Buchstaben die stehen dafür dass
wir bei arznahmitteln die derzeit oft
nicht lieferbar sind die Versorgung
sicherstellen indem wir ein Teil der
Produktion wieder nach Europa
zurückholen ich sag's mal das Wort ich
liebe es einfach es ist Arzneimittel
liefer Engpass bekämpfungs und
versorgungsverbesserungsgesetz also im
Bereich Bürokratie Deutsch funktioniert
unser Land doch wenigstens noch ja ich
glaube eich gesagt dass das Gesetz einen
guten Namen hat weil jeder kennt den
Begriff mittlerweile
alpvvg warum hat das denn so lange
gedauert bis das Gesetz kam also
eineinhalb Jahre nach Kabinettsbildung
es kann nicht ernsthaft von uns verlangt
werden von der Ampel dass wir nachholen
in wenigen Monaten was 10 Jahre lang
versäumt wurde aber ja auch wegen der
SPD die ja in der Regierung war ich sag
ja wir waren mit dabei ich verstecke
mich da ja nicht trotzdem was muss man
sagen s ein erbärmliches Zeugnis dass
wir tatsächlich den Fiebersaft und auch
die Antibiotika für die Kinder nicht
vorhalten können das wird und muss sich
ändern kann man schon sagen welche
Medikamente als nächstes knapp werden
dann würde ich die schon mal besorgen um
dann nachher eine schnelle Markt zu
machen ja das ist ja genau die
Einstellung die unsoziale Einstellung
die wir nicht wollen will ihn hier nicht
zu nah treten aber das geht natürlich
überhaupt nicht ich hoffe dass das nur
eine also sagen mal spaßige also
Bemerkung aber kein echter Vorschlag
gewesen dass ich erwachte
höheres war spaßige Bemerkung ja hfe
dass auch so ist also hier wirklich den
Profit mit den ärmsten und den Kranken
zu machen das geht überhaupt nicht ich
verkaufe Fiebersaft selber hergestellt
das ja wird jetzt wieder knapp aus was
soll denn da sein ja kaprisonne und paar
IBUS fertig ist das
Ding hast du Lust auf
Fiebersaft
ne so 20 € macht das das Kind hat hat
gekauft er ist nicht geschäftsfähig kann
ich probieren ja klar ist im Prinzip das
gleiche wie in
fers ja super auch ein
Schluck do wir probieren das direkt er
mal an den Kindern aus trink die Flasche
mal leer und dann gucken wir mal wie es
dir danach geht falls es doch noch knapp
wird mit dem Fiebersaft her Lauterbach
habe ich selber was
gemischt kleinen fiebersaftmanufaktur
das würde ich ihnen mitgeben das werden
wir jetzt im hab untersuchen lassen also
in unserem arznahmittelinstitut wenn es
Probleme gibt dann muss ich leider
aufsichtsrechtliche Schritte einleiden
das tut mir leid ich bin am Arsch das
war's für mich mit der heute show Ihnen
noch viel Glück vielen Dank alles Gute
wie gesagt wenn Sie ein Job brauchen auf
jeden Fall ich komm ich komme direkt mit
ist ja alles das W nett weil für mich
ist das natürlich jetzt gelaufen das
Ding ne das ist keine Kleinigkeit hier
je nachdem wie das ausgeht das ist
strafrechtlich bedeutsam
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an und
abonniert den Kanal
danke schaut euch gerne weitere Videos
an und abonniert den Kanal
danke oh nein eine Zeitschleife habt ihr
etwa nicht den Kanal abonniert Hilfe
sofort drauf klicken oder ich bin hier
für immer
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an